ooh dr. Anthony foul she is the
country's top infectious disease doctor
he's a head of the National Institute of
Allergy and Infectious Diseases at the
National Institutes of Health as you
know by now he's a member of the White
House coronavirus task force
dr. Falchi thank you so much for joining
us I know you got a lot going on but I
want to start with the story man well
just did about the passengers on the
ship on one hand you have passengers who
were sick who need attention right away
on the other you have so many who are
not sick who are very frightened what
are your thoughts should they be a lot
off the boat oh absolutely
what did there are a couple of things
that that need to be done and we have
experience remember with the diamond
princess in Japan a short while ago
first of all you have to take care of
the people who are ill you just have an
obligation to do that and as quickly as
possible you've got to get the people
who are not sick who are not infected
off the ship now remember there are both
Americans and people from other
countries so we've got to get the
Americans off and we've got to get the
people from the other countries safely
back to their own country in cooperation
with the responsible country but this is
absolutely necessary to do before you
get further spread of the infection it
does seem to be a humanitarian issue and
I want to say the audience there's a
slight delay was dr. Fauci but we can
hear each other so bear with us dr.
Falchi we all know this this is a
pandemic of numbers and I heard you say
the other day the now projections are up
to 240,000 people could die and this is
practicing the social distancing I also
heard you say we should not be
discouraged I was encouraged to hear
that but why should we not be
discouraged when we hear such
frightening numbers because it's within
our power to modify those numbers those
numbers that you heard the other day
that I that dr. Burks and I mentioned
from the White House press conference
when numbers based on a model you model
what the projection might be and the
projection was that even with
considerable mitigation
you still could anticipate between
100,000 and 200,000 deaths however if
you really push hard on mitigation and
data comes in that tells you you're
doing
better than the model you could modify
the model so what I was saying is though
even though we need to anticipate these
rather disturbing numbers we shouldn't
give up and accept it and say okay
that's going to happen we need to push
and push with the mitigation to try and
get that number lower than the projected
number by the model so it doesn't have
to be inevitable so what you're saying
you know the CDC says 25% of the people
don't get symptoms of coronavirus so how
will we know when it's safe to lift the
restrictions well there are a couple of
parameters that you look at one is you
look at the curve of the new infections
of the people who get hospitalized and
the deaths those graphs that we have
been showing at the White House the one
that peeks and then starts coming down
but also we're going to be instituting
tests that can actually show how many
people in the population have been
infected so in addition right now we're
focusing on those who have symptoms
getting them identified isolated trying
to get contact tracing doing physical
separation but what we would like to do
reasonably soon is to get a better feel
for the totality of the infection in the
community even those who've recovered
and you could do that by a relatively
simple antibody test that's one of the
things that we're aiming for as soon as
possible
president Trump says he's considering
banning domestic travel is that your
advice to him no look what we look at
that literally every day it really
depends on what city you're talking
about and from where you are coming so
this is something that you're absolutely
correct is on the table and it's
discussed but no decisions have been
made about banning travel within the
domestic United States dr. Bracci
I know we have to go but there are
reports that you now have to have
security I was very sorry to hear that
for you and I'm wondering the the
personal pressure do you feel pressure
to get this right you know you are the
most respected the most admired when you
speak we listen I'm one
how this has affected you personally you
know it's my job this is the life I've
chosen and I'm doing it I mean I mean
obviously there's a lot of pressure I
mean I would be foolish to deny that but
that's what I do I've been through
crises like this before
dating back you know 37 years from the
very beginning of the HIV epidemic is a
job to do when we've just got to do it
well dr. Fauci listen you're on
doughnuts you're on socks you're on mugs
there's Falchi Friday People magazine
there's a petition and make you sexiest
man alive because people say brains are
sexy so we are all paying attention to
what you're saying I'm wondering how
you're and what your family thinks about
all of this it's really kind of crazy
we try not to pay attention to that and
just focus on the responsibility and the
job that we have that's the most
important thing not that other stuff it
is the most important thing and we are
all cheering you on thank you doctor
fell G good to be with you thank you